Elton John is in the film what was it
like working with the great Elton John
well it was heaven
really wasn't it wasn't it I mean anyone
can chime in on this one yeah like what
are we allowed to say I don't know but
yeah John's one of those people that I
haven't actually looked considered he's
a real person until I met him I mean all
of a sudden he's there and it's I know
you are actually a human being because
so famous yes lovely and he's so good in
the movie he's so good he's
extraordinary in the movie and and he's
every bit the real person I mean you
know this is the larger than life
because we've seen him as a chicken and
Donald Duck and yeah and the songs have
gone through just about every area of my
life yes and then you just get this
really sweet guy who's an extraordinary
pro he's a very very good actor and I
think there's a serious danger he will
steal the movie there's a I believe
there was a moment when his dressing
room was unattended and you visited it
is that true I don't think anyone else
in the cast knows that I don't normally
try on other people's clothes things
case he just came and said this is my
last day whipped it out of my hair no it
it was just this is not Channing anymore
as Elton it was hanging there
tantalizing
all of them the Channing bit yes yes I'm
gonna move on you filthy filthy man
you